[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 voici les principaux titres en
images de ce mardi 2 mai 2010 est à
quelques jours du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle l'écart
peut-il se resserrait encore entrés
emmanuel marc macro et marine le pen
les reports des voix des autres
candidats vont être décisifs reportage à
versailles où françois fillon est arrivé
en tête et attrapes ou jean luc
mélenchon l'a emporté au premier tour
à plaisir le secteur du stade des
peupliers est en chantier
objectif prévenir de nouvelles
inondations après les problèmes survenus
l'an dernier et puis en sport plaisir
fait un pas supplémentaire vers la
montée en fédérale 2 c'est du rugby le
club local s'est imposé face à pontault
combault ce week end
l'actualité marquée aujourd'hui par à
l'ouverture du procès d'un abbé de 44
ans il doit répondre devant la cour
d'assises des yvelines de viol et actes
de barbarie sur trois enseignantes
c'est au cours de séances d'exorcisme au
sein de l'école privée notre-dame de la
sablonnière à goussainville que les
faits se seraient déroulés l'évêché de
versailles a précisé n'avoir aucun lien
avec ce mouvement religieux proche des
milieux d'extrême droite
un hommage à présent celui rendu au être
déportés vers les camps de concentration
et d'extermination nazis lors de la
seconde guerre mondiale en france plus
de 160 mille personnes ont été déportés
entre 1940 et 1945 à de nombreuses
communes ont organisé des cérémonies ce
week end vous le voyez en images et
c'était le cas à trappes en présence
notamment d'une petite fille de déporté
écouter devoir oui je dirai aussi de
plus en plus ce travail de mémoire
parce que il y a à la fois bien sûr se
rappeler mais comme le disait le message
à laquelle donc là auxquels la fondation
a justement participer de même des
amicales et associations
c'est que il y a aussi des devoirs de
transmission et ce n'est pas seulement
regarder
le passé c'est surtout regarder le
présent et regarder l'avenir
propos recueillis par nicolas d'andry la
tombe de l'actrice romy schneider
profané ce week end au cimetière de
boissy sans avoir dans les yvelines la
pierre tombale a été descellé est
déplacé occasionnant d'ouverture du
caveau
les gendarmes de la brigade de
recherches de mantes-la-jolie sont
chargés de l'enquète son rôle dans la
trilogie 6,6 dans laquelle elle incarne
impératrice elisabeth d'autriche valu à
romy schneider un premier succès mondial
et la propulse à 16 ans au sommet de sa
gloire avant de remporter deux fois le
césar de la meilleure actrice
elle repose dans le département aux
côtés de son fils depuis 1982 on passe à
présent à la politique nous avons voulu
savoir comment dans le département à les
voix des candidats battus au premier
tour aller se reporter deux exemples
celui de versailles où françois fillon
était en tête avec 43% des suffrages et
celui de trappes ou jean luc mélenchon a
dépassé benoît hamon de plus de 10%
nicolas landry avec plus de 32 % des
voix jean-luc mélenchon est arrivé en
tête du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle à trappes pour les
électeurs de cette ville ancrée à gauche
le report des voix devrait se faire en
faveur d' emmanuel macron au premier
tour avaient voté benoît hamon et
deuxième tour je vous montrais pour
macron la première tour j'ai voter
mélenchon et deuxième tour je vais voter
macron quand on n'a pas le choix de
toute façon on n'a pas le choix entre
louis aux marines il faut mieux choisir
macron pour les militants dans marche
il est important de mobiliser les
électeurs de crap l'abstention a atteint
près de 30% au premier tour il faut
convaincre d'être un pis aller voter
voter mais pas un chèque blanc mais
surtout votez pour adhérer le programme
de emmanuel macron c'est très important
du côté de versailles françois fillon
est arrivé en tête et a obtenu près de
43% des voix pour le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle plusieurs
situations semblent se présenter pour
des électeurs situés sur une ligne
idéologique traditionnelle du v10 fillon
et 2e tour je ne sais pas encore si je
décroche donc j'ai voté au premier tour
pour françois fillon parce que c'est le
programme qui me plaisait le plus
et bien sûr que je vais voter pour
emmanuel macron parce que je suis contre
le programme d'extrême droite et bye le
pen donc j'ai même pas de doute au
premier tour j'ai voté françois fillon
au second tour je le voterai pour
personne
parce que je suis d'accord ni à jeudi
l'accord avocats des deux candidats de
son côté le front national souhaite
conquérir certains électeurs fillonniste
versailles et et je crois sincèrement à
l'instar de tous les genres du parti
démocrate chrétien que le report va se
faire systématiquement dans le dernier
sondage aux docks sa marine le pen est
créditée de 41% des voix des airs
emmanuel macron à 59% d'intentions de
vote
et sachez que cet après midi les
militants de la france insoumise les
militants de jean luc mélenchon ont
terminé de se prononcer sur les
consignes de vote pour le second tour il
on choisira plus de 30% majoritairement
de voter blanc ou de s'abstenir et cap
sur plaisir à présent vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué si vous êtes se
passer du côté du quartier de la
boissière le secteur du stade des
peupliers est en travaux et des bassins
de rétention d'eau sont actuellement en
construction l'objectif est bien sûr est
d'éviter de nouvelles inondations dans
cette commune après d'importants
problèmes survenus l'année dernière les
terrains construits en 2012
avait été totalement ravagé le reportage
de michael elle me d'euros les images de
patrick jacques de dixmude les pieds
dans l'eau à plaisir ce sera bientôt de
l'histoire ancienne après avoir subi
deux inondations en février et juin 2016
dans le quartier de la boissière
la ville est en train de recréer des
bassins de rétention d'eau au niveau des
terrains des peupliers six semaines de
travaux pour un coût de 160 19000 euros
il y avait des bassins mais en valent
ils vont être déplacés a grandi et on va
aussi buzet de façon beaucoup plus large
l'écoulement des eaux
vous savez quand l'eau circule dans un
usage trop étroits après quand il sort
il ne peut pas se répandre et l'eau a
besoin de place un besoin d'un lit
d'installation quant à elle déborde et à
partir de ce moment là il était question
il fallait absolument revoir tous les
choristes et de l'écoulement il n'y
avait pas que les terrains des peupliers
qui était dans une problématique
il y avait également le quartier des
quelques maisons qui étaient en bas la
petite zone pavillonnaire une fois les
bassins terminé la ville remettra à flot
les terrains synthétiques submergé
pendant les inondations des équipements
utilisés principalement par les
scolaires et les associations sportives
de la commune
ça ça va demandera tout l'été pour
pouvoir effectivement les mettre en
route à partir du mois de septembre
c'est plus d'un million de largement
quand vous l'aménager complètement
autour et bien sûr nous on y avait
ajouté en plus des vestiaires donc ça
coûte vraiment cher mais si aujourd'hui
ce que de vendre les sportifs donc a pas
de raison qu'on ne fasse pas un
accompagnement à ce niveau là mais comme
je vous le disais nous sommes aidés par
rapport aux assurances en parallèle des
travaux sur les terrains la municipalité
va en profiter pour créer à quelques
mètres un parking supplémentaire de 72
places pour fluidifier le stationnement
sur le secteur rendez vous début
septembre pour voir toutes ces
transformations environnement les clubs
de randonnée des yvelines organisée ces
derniers jours des sorties pourra
ramasser les déchets laissés en forêt
nicolas landry était présent à leurs
côtés en forêt de sainte apolline à
neauphle-le-château nettoyer des
sentiers balisés en forêt c'est le
principe d'une rando net une activité
pratiquée par les randonneurs de
l'association animation loisirs sports
d'elancourt notamment dans la forêt
sainte apolline
un autre le château entre des grands
morceaux comme ça des bouts de plastique
des gobelets dès aujourd'hui entre
beaucoup moins de déchets qui a quelques
années auparavant
heureusement ça veut dire que les gens
commencent à être responsabilisés pour
la propreté dans la nature
le comité départemental de la randonnée
pédestre des yvelines a eu l'idée de
mettre en place ces randos net une
action citoyenne et conviviale
c'est vrai que c'est très utile de
ramasser quand même tous ces déchets je
trouve que quand même c'est voilà ça
fait parti d'un de voir qu'on devrait
tous avoir faire peut prendre
connaissance à un certain nombre de
personnes que il est nettement plus
agréable de se promener dans un endroit
propre et être respectueux en quelque
sorte de la nature pour connaître les
prochaines randonnées vous pouvez vous
renseigner auprès des clubs de randonnée
[Musique]
nous passons à notre traditionnel rendez
vous du mardi notre séquence portrait
rencontre avec des yvelinoise et des
yvelinois et aujourd'hui vous allez voir
que retraite ne rime pas forcément avec
laisser aller à 64 ans jean-louis lanier
a repris le chemin de l'école
il suit un cap2 cuisine rencontre avec
ce retraité très actif il n'y a pas
d'âge pour apprendre
la formule est bien connu mais rares
sont les retraités à se lancer
jean-louis lasnier un mini montain de 64
ans n'a lui pas hésité il s'est inscrit
à 1 cap2 cuisine par correspondance mais
non j'ai dans un environnement familial
où on a toujours cuisiné progressivement
c'est un centre d'intérêt ici
qui s'est développée en moins change de
façon plus ou moins je dirais pas
sournoise mais à mon insu et contre la
traite arrivant je me suis dit là voilà
quoi après une carrière passée dans la
gestion des systèmes d'information
jean-louis ne rechigne pas à rouvrir des
livres de cours
même si ce n'est pas son activité
préférée je travaille de façon en
fonction du temps que j'ai et puis de
l'envi que j'aime être aussi certaines
fois on est sûr que quand je rentre des
des journées au je suis en stage le soir
enfin leur milieu d'après midi plus tôt
j'ai absolument aucune envie de me
replonger dans la partie plus littéraire
car si jean louis a décidé de s'engager
dans ce c ap c'est avant tout pour
perfectionner sa pratique de la cuisine
et la faire partager à sa famille et ses
amis on n'est pas sur l'appel ml on
assure préparation de rillettes de
maquereau et n'en fait pas forcément
pour mehdi je prépare mes actes j'ai
toujours une
un penchant pour la cuisine on va dire
goûtu la cuisine avec des aromates avec
des huiles d'olive et de l'ail la
cuisine du sud
donc je fait bénéficier les autres de
mes acquis et c'est pour moi un moment
de joie parce que pendant exemple je
garde ça pour moi
côté pratique jean louis a décroché un
stage chez le restaurateur eric leautey
dans son restaurant de thoiry ce matin
là nous le retrouvons en pleine
préparation des jus de viande ce jeu
vaut va servir à agrémenter un certain
nombre de plateaux le chef doit avoir
atteint aujourd'hui à savoir on ne sait
pas trop mal sorti
pour une première une peur on y en ait
j'ai fait un choix qui était de tenter
de rentrer ici chez
eric noté à paris à ma grande surprise
ils vont accepter tout seul pour le chef
l'âge de ses employés n'a pas
d'importance seule la motivation compte
mélanger les générations peut même être
fédérateur pour sa brigade
il m'a dit je veux passer dans ses
appels sur créteil mais où est le
problème pas au contraire et même quand
on est à la retraite on peut se former
encore et c'est surtout quand on est
passionné quoi donc sa sas c'est un bel
exemple aussi pour les autres le ca paix
prendra fin dans quelques semaines pour
jean-louis il saura s'il est admis en
juin prochain
le retraité passionné de gastronomie
pense déjà à son prochain défi et cela
pourrait bien être une formation en
charcuterie en sport le plaisir rugby
club est toujours en course pour accéder
à la fédérale 2 après leur victoire de
ce dimanche contre pontault combault les
plaisirs avoir longtemps porté à
domicile sur le score de 28 à 13
directions les seizièmes de finale et le
reportage complet avec toutes les images
de cette rencontre
à retrouver sur notre site internet dès
à présent et on termine ce journal avec
un hameau de culture la 7e édition du
trophée d'improvisation culture et
diversité s'est tenue à versailles
vendredi dernier les collégiens de brest
limoges paris chambéry se sont affrontés
pour cette demi-finale au théâtre
montansier l'association trophée d'impro
culture et diversité a été créée
notamment à l'initiative d'un âne
improvisateurs bien connu jamel debbouze
la fondation culture et diversité est
une formation qui a été créé pour
répondre à un certain nombre de
discriminations que vivait un certain
nombre de jeunes dans l'accès à la
culture
c'est effectivement l'une
l'un des princes central de notre
activité de mettre au coeur
effectivement des programmes la question
de la diversité pour permettre aux
jeunes qu'ils viennent de milieux rural
où qu ils viennent des quartiers
populaires d'avoir accès à la culture
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal les
programmes se poursuivre sur notre
antenne à demain
[Musique]